[Music]
in rock star family Wars news frost are
submitted by dad spaghetti hmm not mom's
beginning Tom Petty's daughter and wife
are in a nasty dispute over his legacy
somebody passed last year oh my god
who's Tom Teddy musician and what band
by himself
oh well I think it was yeah damn I don't
know [ __ ] give me a Tom Petty song maybe
I might no I don't think you would it's
a wonderful day to go swimming
how was he popular again and why does he
have legacy boy you grew up by lake
[Applause]
house close up Salinas jumping off like
the waterfall
yeah it's a wonderful guy 17 he died
October 27 lake gyms only like jock jams
but slightly wetter like dirty [ __ ] so
he has two daughters from his first wife
and the eldest daughter named Adria
she has apparently been blocked by Tom
Petty's Widow
Dana who has who was his wife of ten
years until he died
sounds kind of petty Hey okay so Dana is
saying that Adria it was trying to use
Tom's legacy uh for like like kind of
like Paul Newman where you put his face
on salad dressing oh so then that's when
the the widow
blocked it and then now if the daughter
is retaliating and like suing her that's
not her biological mom right he
remarried Tom Petty when he died in 2017
from an accidental overdose of the age
of 66 oh my god he gave his two
daughters so Adria and Anna Kim they
were given equal management votes over
his estate with his widow
Dana so so all three of them share equal
votes so that's why now they're trying
to battle it out to get power over the
estate between the two daughters and how
does this always happen that's man every
time there is an empire built the
children in the widow's fight over it
yeah so a few weeks ago the daughter
filed a petition in LA seeking to have
control of Tom's music catalog which is
said to be worth hundreds of millions of
dollars and so the wife is arguing that
she should be the sole trustee because
she like Tom Petty trusted her to deal
with all of his assets and so now it's
just like there's bumping head but what
about his blood so they're bumping heads
three directions what's to two against
one
yeah that doesn't solve it like if two
of them just like I'll vote her out
because both of them or I guess the way
I understand it is that they each have
got it votes to her so it's like to have
the same votes as like the daughters are
born equal I see the daughters are one
entity yes so complicated she's just
done it three ways baby you know that
they would join up against her maybe
yeah this is like some game of Thrones
in real life it is who's trying to take
over the Empire so what was the specific
thing she wanted to do like was it
actually a salad dressing type of thing
well yeah that's what they're that's
what the wife is claiming that the
daughter was trying to do and then also
so then the the wife she provided
abusive text messages sent by the
daughter regarding a cover design for a
four CD box out of Tom's work titled an
American treasure you can go to work no
buy CDs No then Dana suggested an
alternative cover and then that's one
that a daughter fired back and said
quote it looks like a redneck joke to me
don't come in and [ __ ] things up that
I've been working on for months
like she's pulling up these texts to
show like you see she's been abusive to
me come
and that was every company you know what
he needed to do is we'll write if you
can't work nicely together then by
default all of this goes to charity you
should have done like a willy wonka type
thing what's that one gets it all ticket
hey that'll help sell CDs too cuz it'll
be in the album oh you mean like the
common people get a chance yeah
I don't want common people that have
money like that yeah they won't be
coming that's why people just [ __ ] their
sisters and kept the blood royal
bloodline like that and a lot of
inbreeding started happening you went
crazy just got a mixin that cousin every
once in a while that's still the same
the gene pool is still not that that
varied two cousins by marriage
just trying fast that's gross man gross
let me get the [ __ ] your cousin it's for
the family Oh more look at a greater
good girls I mean I think that's why
it's argh Aryans are crazy right because
they are inbred you have no idea I mean
I get the the the son the little [ __ ]
Joffrey was so [ __ ] crazy cuz he was
a product of every Joffrey had no lips
what his lips go inbreeding they were so
good you're just shaving the actor how
it looks in real life [ __ ] that's
right he's deformed David takes his lips
off that's what inbreeding buzz oh that
makes sense too that holds Irish to when
you him speak normally its way different
yes accents way different you sound like
Shrek Irish the Scottish waiter if I did
a really good job though in making a
great villain yeah he killed it what if
this happens to Tiger and biker alike ax
I know you guys pass and they fight over
the [ __ ] Empire that you built
[Laughter]
thank take a bike in like a all of the
all of it and then Isaac and then Lord
Isaac is like the oldest one like that's
remaining and like we're all dead and
[ __ ] so he's like back
day I remember you got there kids still
have baby voices and then Isaac's an old
man yeah cuz he's the grandpa that's a
whole yeah imagine we're all dead he
like he's the only one that remembers
like everything he's gonna remember our
legacy yeah the brand you don't make
guys like the brand
yeah he's the movie the whole story he's
the one to preserve it yeah isn't that
place else is just trying to put heads
on salad dressing
no we need Isaac to tell it in a very
raspy voice yeah the cloak over his head
and we have a [ __ ] shake on this cane
like this like all [ __ ] old Wizards
sitting in a wheelchair that's okay I
don't want him to be that disabled like
three solid children of the Quan family
to David three solid children to dude
it's crazy all three are coming down 2-1
that's really the name is the name tie
like a biker according to them I could
like a bike does he have any say in the
names they all do oh yeah pecking like a
bye tiny so that's you have to name them
that yeah hey Mike [ __ ] future kid
paper clips we're saving office supplies
you don't want them to become you know
what I mean office supplies you want
them to become digital name of Tiger was
Tory's four tortilla and dice don't you
like that
Tori luck with the TiVo yeah tortilla
rice teller eath yeah what's that
Therese I don't like that it sounds
weird it reminds me of like a like a
like a typo in a fast and furious
credits head told Reese told Reese
William anyway we were talking about Tom
Petty here if he is make his empire off
that one song free-balling it's kind of
like the Eagles where like they have so
many songs but only one of them reached
us he's not from our generation or any
part of our culture
banjo he's American I mean we wouldn't
be my American though like masive
American yeah nationally we're Americans
but he's American what because there's
different types of American there's like
ja rule american mike tyson american
what kind of music you play like
bluegrass what are that rock rock yeah
classic rock yeah just saying bluegrass
feel so distant from life like imagine
being on Jeopardy and that was a
category bluegrass like no chance I just
picture those those boats with the
[ __ ] spinning things I'd only think of
as Disneyland music a bad Joe in a
bucket coyote inside of a [ __ ] overall
like playing a banjo and [ __ ] I always
picture wheat coming out of somebody's
mouth yeah that shit's dope yeah that's
hot that's Tom Petty right not even
close
no it's just classic rock this is the
daughter and the wife that we're talking
about who's who what the wife was way
better than this is she looked kind of
like a doc dr. Quinn Quinn hair right
the daughter looks way worse than the
mom that's why the mom is the mom well
the MA that means the daughter has a lot
of petty geez that's why stepmom that's
how that happens you all right in love
with her for 10 years
good I picked my blood over some but
I've been [ __ ] for 10 years so you
wouldn't it hasn't been ten years yet I
mean this imagine it's going to the land
of imagination if if if it was now maybe
at all and she bore my children yes I
don't think they can turn together
that's what I'm saying though I consider
that gold bigger ish Oh for 10 years
yeah mother of your children is
different
there of dragons measure we got divorced
and then I got what's a mother a chick I
would pick Tyco over the other balls
double dragon
I'm not even give it back to you think
about it his daughter his daughters
40-something years old right that means
you're choosing someone for 10 years
versus 40 years I see yeah I definitely
choose my kids first for sure [ __ ] that
new [ __ ] dude she's new 10 years it's
brand new
yeah [ __ ] button let's say we're all
young and then you know you just
remarried but you have a five-year-old
but then you remarried and you've been
with this woman longer than your
previous woman and then you've been with
this this woman help you raise your
children that's different that's
different
that's a [ __ ] mom she put in
work but she just arm candy and she's
just such dick really really really good
that's how she got there
[Music]